AND CANDANCE OWENS AND GREG
GUTFELD.
5 O'CLOCK IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
IT'S THE STORY SENDING THE
COUNTRY INTO A FRENZY AND
SPARKING WIDESPREAD
CONVERSATIONS.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS IT.
>> WHAT?
>> KANYE WEST HAS IT.
>> WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>> DRAGON ENERGY.
>> NO, STOP, GROSS.
>> INSTEAD OF FOCUSSING ON REAL
ISSUES IMPACTING RACE, WE ARE
FOCUSSING ON KANYE WEST WHO SAID
IT'S NOT ABOUT ANYTHING OF
SUBSTANCE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN WITH A RECORD
COMING UP, HE LIKED DONALD
TRUMP.
>> WHEN THE PRESIDENT BRAGS
ABOUT THE THINGS HE DID FOR
BLACK PEOPLE.
KANYE WEST DIDN'T REPRESENT
THIS MAN HAS BEEN LOST FOR
YEARS.
>> THE AFRICAN-AMERICANS ARE
PREDOMINANTLY DEMOCRATS.
>> I THINK KANYE WEST LOST HIS
MIND.
I THINK IT'S WEIRD.
>> I LOVE IT.
EVEN ASKED SARAH SANDERS ABOUT
IT AT THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
MEETING.
>> KANYE WEST EXPRESSED HIS
ADMIRATION FOR THE PRESIDENT.
>> COVERING ALL RANGE OF TOPICS.
>> HAS THE PRESIDENT REACHED OUT
TO KANYE WEST AND WOULD HE MEET
AT THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> THEY MET DURING THE
TRANSITION.
THAT'S THE ONLY MEETING I AM
AWARE OF OR CONVERSATION BEFORE
EVERYBODY HAS A MELTDOWN.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO WEIGHING
IN THIS WEEK.
>> HE SEES THAT STUFF AND HE IS
SMART.
HE SAID TRUMP IS DOING A MUCH
BETTER JOB THAN THE DEMOCRATS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP COMMENTED
AGAIN TODAY ON KANYE WEST:
THEY REALLY GET IT.
THIS STARTED WITH ONE 7-WORD
TWEET LAST SATURDAY.
I LOVE THE WAY CANDACE OWENS
THINK."
THAT COULD LEAD TO A CULTURE
SHIFT.
"THE FIVE" HAS AN INTERESTING
UPDATE.
CANDACE PREDICTED THIS WOULD
HAPPEN OVER A YEAR AGO.
>> I FIRST SAID IF YOU
UNDERSTOOD KANYE WEST AND YOU
CAN UNDERSTAND THE MOVEMENT OF
DONALD TRUMP.
PEOPLE CAN'T CORRELATE THAT.
IT'S SIMILAR.
ANTI-POLITICAL CORRECTNESS.
>> CANDACE JOINING US TODAY.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT YOU AND
WITH SPEAK WITH YOU.
WE HAVE BEEN HEARING THIS
CHATTER.
YOU PREDICTED THIS AND NOW YOU
HAVE BECOME PART OF THIS CULTURE
SHIFT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I COULD BE BIASSED.
I LOVE THE WAY CANDACE OWENS
THINKS AS WELL.
THIS IS BIZARRE.
I KNEW IT WOULD BE KANYE WEST
THAT WOULD BREAK THROUGH THIS
GROUP THOUGHT ON THE LEFT.
WHAT HE ADVOCATES THE MOST FOR
IN HIS MUSIC IS INDEPENDENCE.
TO BE A CONSERVATIVE MEANS YOU
ALLOW INDEPENDENT THINKING.
THEY DON'T ALLOW THAT ON THE
LEFT WHATSOEVER.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF AN
INTERESTING TIME IN BLACK
AMERICA.
>> GREG, WHEN THIS FIRST
HAPPENED, SOMETHING IS GOING ON
HERE.
THIS IS A CULTURE SHIFT.
YOU DIDN'T FEEL IT WAS A
PUBLICITY STUNT?
>> PEOPLE WILL CALL YOU A
HYPOCRITE WHEN CELEBRITIES TALK
POLITICS AND YOU TELL THEM TO
SHUT UP.
YOU ARE AN ACTOR, JUST ACT.
THIS IS DIFFERENT.
THIS COMES WITH A COST TO HIS
REPUTATION AND FAN BASE AND
ALBUM SALES.
WHEN PEOPLE SAY HE IS DOING THIS
TO PROMOTE ALBUM SALES, THIS IS
GOING TO HURT HIM!
HE DIDN'T CHOOSE A TYPICAL
CUDDLY ISSUE LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE
OR BULLYING OR GUN CONTROL.
HE CHOSE THE MOST HARMFUL ISSUE.
THE MOST DIVISIVE ISSUE PUTTING
HIS ARMS AROUND PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THAT TAKES A LOT OF GUTS.
YOU ARE SEEING A CHANGE IN THE
INTELLECTUAL DARK WEB.
ADAMS AND ROGUE AN.
PEOPLE ARE SEEKING ANOTHER PLACE
TO FIND THE TRUTH BECAUSE THEY
ARE TIRED OF THE NARRATIVE.
I THINK IS PART OF THAT.
>> I THINK YOU OVER-STATE.
>> I TRIED TO OVER-STATE IT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> YOU ARE OVER-STATING
SOMETHING.
>> THAT'S WHAT I AM AFRAID OF
IT.
>> I COP TO THAT.
THE FACT IS PRESIDENT TRUMP GOT
8% OF THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTE
WHICH WAS A BIT OF A SPIKE FROM
WHAT MITT ROMNEY GOT 6%.
RACE IS POLITICS AND POLITICS IS
RACE IN THIS COUNTRY.
VAN JONES FROM CNN SAID ON
ELECTION NIGHT, THIS WAS
WHITE-LASH.
IT WAS ON ONE SIDE AND PEOPLE OF
RECALL ON THE OTHER SIDE.
THE FEROCITY OF THE REACTION OF
KANYE WEST'S SUPPORT OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND YOU CANDACE
IS A MEASURE OF THAT.
>> ROMNEY WAS AT 6% AND TRUMP AT
8%.
IF YOU GO TO 10% FOR A
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE NATIONALLY,
THAT BRINGS ALL DIFFERENT KINDS
OF COUNTIES IN PLAY.
WITH THE COUNTRY DIVIDED, THAT
RAZOR MARGIN COULD HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT.
WHAT SHOW DID YOU DO, CANDACE?
>> BEFORE KANYE WEST TWEETED ME,
IT WAS "WATTERS WORLD."
>> I WANTED TO ESTABLISH THAT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> AND FOR JUAN WILLIAMS, I AM
SORRY.
>> I WISH HE WERE TODAY.
>> I PUT A HURT ON HIM.
HE IS STILL RECOVERING.
>> I WOULD SAY ONE THING, I
THINK KANYE WEST AND DONALD
TRUMP HAVE SO MUCH IN COMMON
BESIDES THE DRAGON ENERGY.
THEY BOTH THRIVE ON CONTROVERSY.
BOTH ARE EGOTISTICAL.
BOTH ARE LOVED AND HATED.
THEY DRIVE THEIR SUPPORTERS
CRAZY BUT ALSO MAKE THEIR
SUPPORTERS DANCE.
HE SAID THIS IS NOT POLITICAL,
KANYE WEST.
HE SAID IT'S NOT ABOUT
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRATS.
IT'S ABOUT INDEPENDENT THOUGHT.
I AGREE WITH THAT.
I DON'T THINK HE IS TALKING
ABOUT THE BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT OR
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT TRUMP
HAS DONE FOR THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE POLICY, I
DON'T THINK TRUMP HAS HURT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN IN COUNTRY.
YOU LOOK AT FOOD STAMPS ARE
DOWN.
SHOOTINGS ARE DOWN IN CHICAGO
AND BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT.
THINGS ARE NOT TERRIBLE IN THE
BLACK COMMUNITY AS A RESULT OF
DONALD TRUMP'S POLICY.
>> THERE IS A REAL THING CALLED
DRAGON ENERGY.
IT IS REAL.
TRUMP IS A MOTIVE STAR.
KANYE WEST IS A MOVIE STAR.
THERE ARE OTHERS.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP DURING THE
CAMPAIGN DID SOME THINGS THAT
REALLY WERE EGREGIOUS FROM THE
POINT OF FEW FROM
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
>> NAME 1.
>> WHEN HE FEIGNED IGNORANCE OF
DAVID DUKE.
I DON'T KNOW DAVID DUKE.
I HAVE TO RESEARCH IT.
IN CHARLOTTESVILLE, THE NEO-NAZI
MARCH, HE EQUATED THE 2 SIDES.
>> THE EXTREME LEFT WITH THE
EXTREME RIGHT.
>> 100%.
>> I SAID TO THE PRESIDENT,
FACE-TO-FACE THAT I THOUGHT HE
NEEDED TO REACH OUT.
I LOOKED AROUND AND EVERYBODY IN
MAR-A-LAGO WAS WHITE.
I SAID YOU NEED BLACK FACES
HERE.
THAT'S A REALITY.
HE HAS TO FACE IT.
THERE IS A STRUCTURAL PROBLEM
WITH RACE AND POLITICS IN IN
COUNTRY.
DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE HE HAS
DRAGON ENERGY AND IS THIS
INDEPENDENCE THINKER HAS THE
ABILITY TO BUST OUT OF THAT 8%.
>> CANDACE, LET'S TALK ABOUT
THIS.
IN TERMS OF THE CULTURE SHIFT.
MINORITY WOMEN AND CONSERVATIVE
WOMEN LIKE YOURSELF AND MYSELF
TAKE OFFENSE IS CULTURE ELITE
TELLING US WHAT TO THINK AND
BELIEVE.
WHETHER WE ARE ON THE RIGHT
TRACK OR WE ARE DELIRIOUS TO
SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT AND
REPUBLICANS.
KANYE WEST IS PUSHING BACK
AGAINST THAT POLARIZING THINKING
THAT TRIES TO PUT PEOPLE IN
BOXES AND STIGMATIZE YOU.
>> IT'S MONOLITHIC THINKING.
THAT'S WHAT I AM PUNCHING BACK
AGAINST.
AT THE END OF THE DAY IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE.
WHEN YOU SAY HE NEEDS TO HAVE
MORE BLACK FACES.
THAT MEANS NOTHING.
WE SAW WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA, HE
HAD EVERY BLACK ARTIST IN THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR PHOTO-OPES AND
CHICAGO WAS WORSE OFF.
I NEED TO SEE BLACK RESULTS.
IT'S INSULTING PEOPLE SAY WE
HAVE BEYONCE AND JAY-Z ON STAGE.
THAT'S AN UPHILL CHALLENGE.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THAT'S TRUE.
YOU CAN SEE THAT WITH THE RECORD
LEVEL OF INCARCERATIONS OF BLACK
AMERICANS.
THERE ARE POINTS TO BE MADE HERE
TO SUPPORT THESE THEORIES.
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THIS
COUNTRY, THERE IS A GROUP THINK
TRYING TO POLLUTE YOUR MIND AND
DIDN'T RESPECT FREEDOM OF
THOUGHT OR EXPRESSION.